Destinee - is coming to PS 5 and series
X with a free upgrade there's more
evidence for a cheaper series X model
and in the ever-growing list of podcasts
Sony launched one for The Last of Us
I'm chasity and this is your save state
for Tuesday June 9
good news Guardians especially if you
like to save money like me because
destiny 2 is coming to next-gen consoles
with a free upgrade destiny 2 will
launch on both PS 5 and Xbox series X
and it's a free upgrade so including the
new expansion anything you've purchased
on ps4 gets transferred to PS 5 and Xbox
one gets transferred to series X and yes
it supports 4k 60fps intergenerational
cross play is supported on console
families which means ps4 and PS 5
players can play together and Series X
and Xbox one players can also play
together
Bungie is looking into true cross play
but that won't happen this year and
there's no release date on next-gen
versions this news was part of the
stream revealing the new expansion
called beyond light and that's out
September 22nd on all current platforms
and that content also transfers to
next-gen and we have a video going into
more detail about be online and the new
season right here on GameSpot some
rumors have been floating around about
another cheaper version of the Xbox
series X and now there's even more
evidence there have been rumors about a
cheaper ostensibly less powerful version
of the series X in the works called
Project Lockhart one Twitter user found
the term Lockhart within the windows OS
it's listed alongside other project
names like Scorpio anaconda and Durango
it's rumoured to be a disc free digital
only version of the console but note
that Microsoft has never commented on
the rumor as someone who got a ps4 slim
and never got a pro I kind of regret it
but I also do love saving money what do
you guys think does the cheaper version
entice you or are you going all-in on
the series X there's so many new
podcasts out there that I can't keep up
but here's another one for the list
because Sony and Naughty Dog have
launched an official one for the Last of
Us in this official podcast developers
cast and more reflect on the Last of Us
posted by stand-up comedian Christian
Spicer it's a limited series with 8
episodes releasing on Tuesday starting
today they'll start by covering the
first game then shipped to the second
game with the episode releasing on July
7th as a reminder part 2 is out next
Friday June 19th
director Neil druckmann isn't sure where
a naughty dog will go at
this he said quote as you start wrapping
things up creatively there are fewer and
fewer responsibilities and my mind can't
help but think about the next thing so
yeah the next thing could be a part
three and the next thing could be some
new IP and speaking of Sony will be
covering the reveal event for ps5 this
Thursday on GameSpot at 1:00 p.m.
Pacific Time 4 p.m. Eastern so hang out
join in the chat and pretend you're
working I won't tell
but if you miss all of that we'll cover
it right here on safe state that's your
news but we're also right in the middle
of play for all where we're raising
money for black lives matter and kovat
19 relief efforts play for all is a
multi week event where we're having
charity streams Monday through Friday at
12 p.m. Pacific 3 p.m. Eastern so check
those out tomorrow we're playing apex
legends with the voices of Miraj and
Watson and Danny O'Dwyer joins us on
Friday plus we're also bringing you the
biggest news exclusives interviews and
more for more info check out the links
in the description that's it for safe
State today I'm chastity and if you want
to hear me talk about TV and movies go
check out GameSpot universe
reach out to me on Twitter at chastity
underscore Vee and Kurt will be here
tomorrow with more news see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]